DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AND THEY ARE
COMING FOR YOU.
AND THAT’S "THE ANGLE."
JOINING ME NOW AS LARRY KUDLOW,
WHITE HOUSE ECONOMIC ADVISOR.
LARRY, GOOD TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
IF BIDEN --
>> THANK YOU.
>> Laura: WAS SERIOUS ABOUT
EMPOWERING AMERICAN WORKERS, HE
DID THE BIG POPULIST PUSHED
TODAY, WHY DIDN’T HE ACTUALLY DO
THAT DURING HIS 40 PLUS YEARS IN
D.C.?
>> THAT’S A GOOD POINT.
HE HAD HIS CHANCE, PARTICULARLY
WITH OBAMA LAST DAY HERE BEFORE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE HAD ONE OF THE WORST
RECOVERIES IN HISTORY.
LOOK, YOU GO DOWN THE LIST AND
LOOK AT THAT CAMPAIGN,
DOCUMENTS, FIRST OF ALL, HE
INTENDS TO REPEAL EVERY TAX CUT
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP PUT AN END
TO REJUVENATE THE ECONOMY, AND
LET ME MAKE THIS POINT, DESPITE
THE MANTRA OF THE DEMOCRATS THAT
ALL TAX CUTS HELP THE RICH, THE
TRUMP TAX CUTS DID EXACTLY WHAT
WE HOPED.
THAT IS MIDDLE INCOME,
BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS, LOWER WAGE
WORKERS PERFORMED THE BEST.
NOT ONLY ARE THEY THE LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN HISTORY BUT
THERE WAGE INCREASE WAS FASTER
THAN THE TOP 1%.
AND THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATES FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND HISPANICS
AND ASIANS AND WOMEN WERE
HISTORIC LOWS.
PLUS, BIDEN IS GOING TO ADD NEW
TEXAS.
TODAY HE SAID, BY THE WAY, HE
DOESN’T WANT TO HAVE A STOCK
MARKET, HE DOESN’T WANT TO HAVE
SHAREHOLDERS INVOLVED IN THE
STOCK MARKET.
BESIDES PENSION FUNDS AND EVEN
UNION PENSION FUNDS, 51% ARE
INVESTED IN THE STOCK MARKET,
WHICH I MIGHT ADD IS UP 40%
SINCE -- HE’S GOING TO REWRITE
ALL OF THE REGULATORY REDUCTIONS
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP PUT IN TO
HELP SMALL BUSINESSES AND
WORKERS.
>> Laura: THAT’S GOING TO BE A
NIGHTMARE.
A NIGHTMARE.
>> HE IS FOR THE GREEN NEW DEAL,
WHICH WILL END -- HE CAN TALK
ABOUT COAL MINES ALL HE WANTS
BUT IF YOU GO WITH THE GREEN NEW
DEAL, THAT MEANS ALL FOSSIL
FUELS GONE.
>> Laura: LARRY, LET ME GET IN
HERE, BECAUSE I THINK WHAT BIDEN
SAID HE IS, OBVIOUSLY, HE’S AT A
DISADVANTAGE IN ARGUING THESE
POINTS.
IT’S OBVIOUS, HIS WHOLE CAREER
SPEAKS TO INTERNATIONALISM AND
SUPPORTING JOBS TO CHINA.
BUT HE ALSO CAN SAY NOW, BECAUSE
YOU ALL HAVEN’T DONE IT, I’M
GOING TO BRING BACK DRUG
MANUFACTURING.
I’M GOING TO DO THIS.
TRUMP SAYS HE WOULD DO IT, I’M
GOING TO DO IT.
WHY HASN’T THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION MOVED ON THAT
ORDER?
I KNOW PETER NAVARRO AND OTHERS
HAVE BEEN PUSHING IT WITH
REPORTERS TODAY.
WHY ARE WE NOT BRINGING BACK
SOME OF THESE DRUGS AND BRINGING
THEM BACK STAT, TO USE A MEDICAL
TERM?
>> THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE
TRYING TO DO, NOT ONLY
PHARMACEUTICALS, BUT
SEMICONDUCTORS --
>> Laura: WHAT’S HOLDING IT
UP?
>> THERE’S NOTHING HOLDING IT
UP, WHEN WE COME OUT WITH OUR
PROGRAM -- WE ARE ALREADY IN
DISCUSSION WITH LOTS OF
COMPANIES BASED IN CHINA.
WE HAD A DISCUSSION TODAY, A
LEADING SEMICONDUCTOR COMPANY IS
SELLING THEIR FACTORIES IN CHINA
AND COMING BACK HOME.
WE WILL GIVE THEM THE LOWEST
CORPORATE TAX RATE, WE WILL GIVE
THEM PERHAPS TAX CREDITS,
CERTAINLY 100% EXPENSES.
WE MAY USE SOME GOVERNMENT FUNDS
TO PAY FOR THEIR MOVING COSTS.
WE HAVE A WHOLE CAMPAIGN PLAN.
WE ARE WARNING AMERICAN
INVESTORS NOT TO INVEST IN
CHINESE STOCKS BECAUSE OF THE
FRAUDULENT ACCOUNTING.
THE SAVINGS PLAN AND THE
RAILROAD RETIREMENT FUND, SO WE
ARE DOING EXACTLY THAT AND WE
ARE TAKING STEPS TO DEAL WITH
THIS HONG KONG DISASTER.
I DON’T THINK IT’S RIGHT TO SAY
WE HAVEN’T DONE IT, WE’VE BEEN
DOING IT.
AND THE TAX REFORM ITSELF, WE
MADE IT SO EASY TO REPATRIATE
PROFITS AND CAPITAL COME BACK TO
THE UNITED STATES.
IN A SECOND TRUMP TERM YOU WILL
SEE A LOT MORE OF THAT.
>> Laura: YOU CAN COMMIT
TONIGHT THAT WE WILL BRING BACK
THESE CRUCIAL DRUGS AND THE
MANUFACTURING, EVEN IF THE PRICE
GOES UP A LITTLE BIT AT HOME, IN
ORDER TO SECURE OUR STOCKPILE OF
CRITICAL MEDICATION.
>> I THINK, LAURA, THAT WE
LEARNED, AND NOT THE ONLY
COUNTRY, OTHER COUNTRIES, BUT
THE UNITED STATES LEARNED THAT
CHINA IS NOT TO BE TRUSTED,
PERIOD.
FALSE.
AND THAT WE CANNOT RELY ON THESE
LONG COMPLICATED SUPPLY CHAINS
COMING OUT OF CHINA.
I THINK YOU’LL SEE THE WHOLE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
YOU WILL SEE BUSINESS SCHOOL
PROFESSORS SAYING NOW THAT
SUPPLY CHAINS DON’T WORK, GOT TO
BRING THEM BACK HOME BECAUSE
CHINA IS NOT RELIABLE, THEY’RE
NOT THE ONLY ONES WHO ARE
UNRELIABLE BUT I HEAR THE SAME
THING FROM PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD SO THAT IS GOING TO BE A
MAJOR CHANGE.
BUT WE HAVE GOT TO CONTINUE LOW
TAXES AND DEREGULATION AND FAIR
TRADE DEALS.
IF WE DO THAT, WE WILL COME
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC.
I THINK WE WILL GET 20% GROWTH
IN THE SECOND HALF.
HOPEFULLY THE VIRUS HOT SPOTS
WILL BE SUBDUED AND MEDICATED
AND I THINK WE’RE GOING TO HAVE
A BIG BANG IN 2021.
WE WERE COMING INTO THE STRONG,
YOU KNOW THAT.
DEREGULATION WORKS, THE ENERGY
WORKS, THE TRADE WORKS.
WE JUST HAD THE USMCA, WE JUST
HAD THE USMCA, THE PRESIDENT WAS
HERE, A LOT OF GOODWILL --
>> Laura: LARRY, REAL QUICK.
ISN’T IT REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND, COMPARING OUR
RESPONSE TO COVID TO EUROPE’S
RESPONSE, OUR ECONOMY IS FARING
FAR BETTER THAN THE MAJOR
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES.
I DON’T THINK A LOT OF VOTERS
KNOW THAT, BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE CHARTS, IT’S UNDENIABLE.
TRUMP POLICIES POSED TO COVID
ARE SEMINAR WORK AND COME
ECONOMICALLY.
BIDEN WANTS TO TURN IT ALL BACK
BY LOCKING US ALL DOWN.
A REAL QUICK, LARRY.
>> WE HAVE A STRONG V-SHAPED
RECOVERY.
THEY WERE COVERING IN EUROPE, BY
THE WAY, BUT WE DO HAVE A STRONG
RECOVERY.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS IN CLOSING,
I AND CONCERNED ABOUT THE VIRUS
HOT SPOTS AND I WILL SAY THIS,
IF YOU WANT TO REOPEN OUR
ECONOMY, IF YOU WANT TO LET THE
PRESIDENT REBUILD THE ECONOMY
FOR THE SECOND TIME, THE BEST
THING WE CAN DO IS TAKE THE
SAFETY MEASURES, USE THE
FACE MASKS, THE PRESIDENT SAID
THAT TONIGHT WITH SEAN, KEEP THE
DISTANCE INCOME OF THE TESTING
IS SO IMPORTANT IN THE
HOT SPOTS, AND PERSONAL HYGIENE.
IF YOU PRACTICE THAT THEN WE
WILL STABILIZE THE HOT SPOTS AND
WE WILL BE OFF TO THE RACES FOR
A STRONG ECONOMY.